hey guys how's it going I'm getting
ready to do a wonderful look for you
today it is called fall I'm prepping my
skin by doing my normal little routine
here just putting on a little stuff now
for this look I'm taking the inspiration
from the outdoors I'm thinking about
trees and thinking about grass I'm
thinking about all of those things let's
get started shall we
we shall I'm gonna use this stuff
because I would like to be flawless when
you're playing Mortal Kombat and your
opponent doesn't even touch you that's
what I like to call a flawless victory
oh my gosh covergirl call me maybe now
coming baby no call me definitely so the
first thing that we're gonna do is we're
gonna do the eyes the eyes are the most
important because they are the windows
to the soul it I want my soul to say
happy fall we're just gonna close up of
that let me to close I've got a couple
of the little colors here so I want to
kind of make it look like a fall sunset
so start by lining
these aren't achieving the look that I
was hoping that I was gonna get we're
gonna use this really great palette here
this greenish color we want to have this
at the base of the eye because grass
goes on the ground
all right the grass is coming along
nicely we're just gonna go over that a
little more with this powder to set it
we're gonna take this blue and we're
gonna make this the sky because the sky
is a very important part of fall we're
gonna take the sky and we're just going
to make the sky your eyebrow this is
something that you can wear to a parade
Thanksgiving dinner with your family at
Thanksgiving dinner alone now if you're
able to see there's a beautiful blue hue
starting to form on my eyebrows now
under that we're gonna take this nice
little teal and put that on the brow
bone
now as you can see this is starting to
really come together nicely we've got
this great orange now this is gonna be
the color for our sunset oh this is
gonna kind of just work in real nice so
just get that orange in there a little
bit make sure you do the same on both
sides now this other palette that we
have here has a another kind of a gold
color and with this gold we want to have
this and we also want that to kind of
highlight the inner part of your eye
here so this is going to kind of pull
the whole look together so this is very
important to take this and just bring
everything in this actually looks kind
of cool but I will not be wearing this
at Thanksgiving dinner these you're
probably gonna want to go over some of
the blues again just to make sure
everything looks okay make it a little
more prominent blend it in with your top
you really want these colors to stand
out and on camera I don't think you can
actually tell um oh yeah you can tell
I'm bright they are so let's go back in
maybe get a little more with this teal
now you might be thinking
those blues really are running together
how am I going to make this be something
that I can wear out and not have people
say hey your eyebrows aren't blue enough
well make sure you're going outside of
your brow so that people are really able
to tell that this is a statement that
you're making and statement that you're
making can be anything it could be
unbeautiful unbold I'm blind doesn't
really matter I'm just gonna line this
lower lash and we want to extend this
out so that it really looks like a leaf
you want to scream hey ah I don't know
what you want to scream 9-1-1 call for
help so I just made a little mistake
here so I'm gonna go with it um I'd like
to call this a tree branch so we're
going to continue with this theme it's
the branch of life so we have our tree
over here and I think over here maybe we
might want like a fall leaf it's gonna
kind of well it may connect I'm not sure
what's gonna happen that's a leaf go in
and do a little contouring now if Kim
Kardashian or to take this look and run
with it you know she would be all about
the contouring because that girl is not
even real sorry it keep me pretty gold
to the mix now don't worry about when
you get home and having to take this off
because it doesn't matter let's just go
in add a little more gold the tree
secret is gonna call and be like we
don't even care that your boobs aren't
big we want this makeup job that you did
now if you're feeling pretty confident
about yourself and you think that you
look good and you think that you're done
you're not you need to show these lips
who's boss so by doing that we're going
to use this really great orange lipstick
Jenna you want to see how pretty I am
what do you think so what I was doing is
a saline this is a big yes yeah time I
come up that's what I'm a little
concerned about should we go to the club
hmmm maybe just wait a few yeah few
hours well I think that's all I want to
do now to this this face I might add a
little blush just in case I want people
to thing but I'm not a dead body a
little blush to the forehead just to
really really pull it all together I
think I might also contour my face with
this this really completes the look
I'm not going to use any mascara because
I don't want people to see my eyelashes
fall is not all about lashes fall is all
about this thank you guys for watching I
hope you enjoyed my tutorial and I think
you're gonna look really good doing this
let me know where you guys decide to
wear this look that's all I have for you
I'm now gonna go to the club at 11
o'clock in the morning and wait for them
to open the guide later
Oh bye